we had to turn to the federal government
for help to to state government for help
i've
i've stood in line for government cheese
i've stood in line for bread and i knew
at 11 years old that that was not
america's best that there was more for
us we didn't live that way in florida
we didn't have to pay with monopoly
money
for groceries in the grocery store and
that's what we were doing in colorado
my stepdad he ended up getting work in
aspen when i was about 12 and we moved
to the western slope of colorado and
that really was the best thing that
could have ever happened to us
we moved into a community
that
wasn't just telling us where to get a
hand out but they were offering a hand
up
all right i'm dave rubin and we are live
in studio today with the congresswoman
from colorado's third district lauren
bobert welcome to the reuben report
thanks so much for having me on dave
this is fantastic to actually be in
person with someone talking face to face
imagine that face to face we've got what
about four feet between us are we in any
sort of legal trouble could this get you
kicked out i mean according to political
science we are in deep trouble right now
what about regular science i know
political sciences were in a lot of
trouble i think i think we're okay with
regular science all right we got you all
the way out to crazy california you're
here for a couple days how do you feel
in california you come from the i would
say
relatively free state of colorado or the
once really free state once you're
really hanging on freeze dates yes we
are hanging on um i do believe that
there are more conservatives in colorado
uh than the average person would would
know uh we are slowly turning into
california and really it's been quicker
than any of us would have liked to have
seen but we have a governor from
california who wants to mimic everything
that's that's happened here there's been
documentaries that have gone out the
rocky mountain heist there's a book
the colorado blueprint and you know they
they were kind of sounding the alarms of
what was happening and that colorado was
really
a petri dish for all of these liberal
policies that democrats want to
take nationwide and if they can do it in
colorado they can do it anywhere
successfully and so that's what we're
seeing and we didn't have any voices in
colorado so i'm really happy
to be that loud voice in colorado right
now to let everyone know what's
happening to us there yeah and i've done
a couple events in colorado over the
last couple of years although
unfortunately none in the last year and
a half but when i was on tour with
jordan peterson i went and a few other
things and what i noticed when i talked
to a lot of people was dave dave could
you make sure all the california people
stopped coming here
are you still hearing a lot about that
yes we still have californians coming
and these political refugees are
bringing their bad policies with them
and so i mean that's really devastating
to our communities because we like our
rural way of life and we don't want that
uh those that urban lifestyle hey buddy
hi
i have i have dogs i have goats
we're not only getting this out but
clyde does have to leave
that's so sweet
clyde
well we have the outtake for the show
climb you gotta go now hi
guys we have a treat or uh
that brings me a lot of joy i i love i
love animals
yes wild yeah so people are constantly
opening the door and breaking into your
interviews sorry you were saying
i i don't know where we were um but with
uh with everything that's that's where
were we we were talking about the
californians coming yes and they're
bringing their bad policies with them
and so we there really is an urban and
rural divide and we want to keep rural
colorado rural but unfortunately in
these high mountain ski resort towns
that i represent a lot of californians
can afford to move there and they're
bringing the same policies that they're
fleeing from so i ask this to every
conservative or republican official that
i talk to like when the people come
do you think they have no idea that they
voted for those policies that they're
now fleeing and realize that maybe they
should think about things a little bit
differently now
no i i i mean because their actions
would prove that they think they could
flee from their problems and
unfortunately there is a lower class um
of people who cannot afford to flee
those bad policies that they have voted
in and implemented and so they get to
leave pack up and and go to somewhere
with lower taxes and better
opportunities and still have a beautiful
scenic view
but there is another class that's left
behind that cannot afford to make that
same move and they are the ones who are
stuck in in
in that
terrible economy and a horrible state
where they are left now to depend on the
government to help uh in their
situations or or
um even in these failing economies where
taxes are just too high to afford the
homes that they want to live in um so i
mean it's really
impacts them more than anything
and then they come to these other states
and bring those same policies so i
wouldn't think that they knew uh what
impact they are having on these
communities yeah the idea that they're
leaving the people who can't afford to
move is sort of interesting too you know
i realized this morning when i was
thinking about how i wanted to do this
interview that you know if you take sort
of a new crop of congress people
and you think about mostly the democrat
side we all know everything about aoc we
know everything about ilhanomar probably
too much more than we want to know we
know everything about ayana presley and
the rest of the crew but we don't
actually know that much from a national
perspective about you and it's like it
seems like people should be talking
about you just as much
but that's not really how the media
operates because you're a scary
conservative
scary conservative i should be the
democrats dream story i i was raised a
democrat and i i was dependent on
government and i thought i always would
be because when you're stuck in that
cycle of poverty it's really hard to
break free a bit yeah can you tell
everyone your story yeah absolutely um
so i was born in orlando florida um my
mom was single we lived with her parents
my grandparents i i attribute a solid
foundation to them and and the few years
that they that they had me in their home
but my mom just up and moved us to
colorado when i was four years old
she met him she met a guy and moved to
an apartment in aurora and i think her
pride
was was too big to go back home to her
parents things kind of got a little
rough he wasn't
the prince charming that she thought he
was going to be
but then eventually she had my first
younger brother with him and she didn't
want to have another child not have a
father
and uh so
we were stuck we were here uh
through the good the bad the and the
very ugly and that led us to
times where he wasn't working and we had
to turn to the federal government for
help to to state government for help
i've
i've stood in line for government cheese
i've stood in line for bread and i knew
at 11 years old that that was not
america's best that there was more for
us we didn't live that way in florida i
we didn't have to pay with monopoly
money
for groceries in the grocery store and
that's what we were doing in colorado
my stepdad he ended up getting work in
aspen when i was about 12 and we moved
to the western slope of colorado and
that really was the best thing that
could have ever happened to us
we moved into a community
that
wasn't just telling us where to get a
hand out but they were offering a hand
up and they started sharing with my mom
conservative values um so she listened
and even changed her voter registration
to republican
but she didn't vote republican
she went to process yes yes she
she got to the ballot box and said no
i'm scared i i'll lose everything if
republicans are
in charge um we didn't have enough
stability for her to to let go of that
mindset um and so
i started working at 15 years old at the
rifle mcdonald's and i can still
remember bringing mom home that first
paycheck i remember the dignity that had
come with earning a paycheck putting my
hand to something and creating wealth
and that's something that never left me
i learned at a very young age that i
could do a better job taking care of
myself than the government ever had so i
began to develop these conservative
principles not even knowing what was
happening and my husband and i uh we we
met uh when he moved to colorado to work
in the oil and gas industry and
you know it
we knew that we could build a great life
together a successful life together i
had only ever wanted to be a mom i
didn't have dreams to to be a business
owner to
be a doctor or lawyer certainly not a
politician
i just wanted to be a mom my mom was my
hero and someone that i looked up to and
so whenever we when we started our life
together we wanted to start our family
right away and that left me with a very
difficult decision to make my senior
year of high school because now i have a
child and a family and i didn't want to
go back to the lines i i didn't want
government cheese for for my boy
and so i quit high school and i took a
management position with mcdonald's that
was very good for my age and that was
more valuable they took you into a
management position after quitting high
school just like that yes wow yes no
degree necessary wow
wow yes well it was really
it was the hours that i needed to work
for that shift manager position of why i
needed to quit high school i was working
nights with them and they said to be a
shift manager we need you in this day
shift and so i had to leave high school
to
to take on that role and for me there
was
there was more value in earning that
paycheck for my family than sitting in
geography class for another two months
until i graduate high school do you
remember what you were making per hour
at that point 45 a year 45 a year 45 000
a year oh that's points you were in the
management position do you remember what
you were making per hour at mcdonald's
about 7.50 so there was there was um
there was
several different pay periods that i had
with them i i started out um i think
it's 6 15 an hour and then i was about
750 an hour and then i went to a
salaried position how much of that
shapes your economics the way you think
about it now because you know to be a
good person i thought we have to have
everyone making or the lowest people
have to make 15 that means you're a good
moral person if you scream that should
you have been making 15 an hour then no
i worked for every extra dollar that i
did earn um and
it really gave me an opportunity that i
wouldn't have had if minimum wage was 15
look at how how many things are
automated now
now that we're reaching 15 per hour
mcdonald's has kiosks instead of the 15
16 17 year old high school
student that was coming in and earning a
paycheck and so i would not have had the
opportunities that have shaped my world
view my economic view had minimum wage
been so high because they would not have
been able to afford to invest in me and
provide that opportunity for for me to
to have a work ethic and and develop my
life skills so i actually didn't know
that part of your story but it's a
pretty perfect through line to you own a
restaurant yeah yes yeah so you were
doing something right back in high
school at mcdonald's yes i'm a very
spontaneous person by nature sometimes i
see it as my greatest downfall but
sometimes it works out pretty well and i
i ended up leaving mcdonald's and i went
to the oil and gas industry for a while
i was filing some papers at a a local
company and then decided to go out in
the field and do work and i was a
pipeline technician
so locating pipeline doing cathodic
protection um without an engineering
degree uh it's possible to do work
without a four-year
college degree and uh and so i was
locating pipelines i was gpsing the
pipelines making maps of them doing
cathodic protection which um is
we install anodes um to protect the pi
pipe from corroding and and so it's just
this fascinating part of my job that i
loved and got to drive all around the
valley and hike up and down mountains
locating these pipes and making sure
they were protected
and then the oil and gas industry
started to be heavily regulated and
colorado
saw the industry pulling out
so a lot of us our days were numbered i
ended up leaving and decided to be a
stay-at-home mom i had three boys then
and um said you know i'm gonna just be
with my boys for a while
and unfortunately a little bit later um
it got worse and so my husband ended up
running out of contracts and he wasn't
working in the industry anymore and we
said we needed a plan b uh there was a
local restaurant that shut down
and uh it was one of our favorites it
was called the cowboy cafe um
c-a-l-f-a yes
yes
and
they closed down and they had a for rent
sign in the window and we drove by one
day and said maybe
maybe we could do this and so we went in
it was a great deal to lease the place
um the equipment was there and we
decided whenever he went back to work to
start investing those um his paycheck
into the restaurant and and opening it
up very spontaneous never owned a
restaurant before
but i wanted a way to give back to my
community a lot of our friends were
unemployed and they needed opportunity
again and that
opportunity wasn't there in the oil and
gas industry like it had been and so we
opened up we hired our waitresses our
our kitchen staff and we were just a
western themed restaurant
wanting to give excellent service to our
community
and it was it was a pretty great place
when we first opened i didn't have a lot
of money i didn't have any money for
advertising so we went door-to-door on
the first day to each business and said
hey come in and have a free meal on us
and that was cheaper than any
advertising i could have done and it
worked people liked it and they were
coming back
so what you may have heard about the
restaurant
a few weeks after we opened our western
themed restaurant there was an
altercation where a man was brutally
beaten outside of the restaurant show up
in the morning there's
there's crime scene tape everywhere
there's police officers i was talking
with some of the officers that i knew
asking what had happened
and there was a man who was beaten
pretty badly and he ended up losing his
life and so that immediately prompted
the question of me how am i going to
take care of everyone how am i going to
protect the people that are around me
so i went across the street and talked
to a local
gun dealer a gun salesman and uh and i
asked about colorado's carry laws he
said well you can carry openly without a
permit
so that's what i did i began to open
carry soon after that my waitresses
began to open carry and the next thing
you know shooter's grill was being
called the safest restaurant in america
shooter's grill so there is the name
yeah and there have been no shootings no
shooters grill people are not murdering
each other or anything like that you
know it's interesting because you
mentioned at the top that your story the
democrats should sort of love your story
but in a way i get why they hate your
story you came from nothing you worked
hard you did a bunch of stuff you kept
growing you care about family right
that's a problem yes they can't have the
success story right
they they are okay with you turning a
blind eye to their failures you know if
the um if the man in the white house has
a son who's lost three laptops and is uh
addicted to smoking parmesan cheese you
know we can turn a blind eye to that um
if a cnn uh
analysis you know gets caught doing some
very very horrendous inappropriate
things on a zoom meeting then you know
that's okay as long as he comes on and
says i'm sorry um but no that that real
life
when things get tough you get tougher
and
and you make success out of failures you
learn from your mistakes and you
continue you don't let
that
hold you back or keep you down and and
you offer to other people a way to have
success in their lives that is what they
hate so when did you decide okay i've
got these ideas my life's in order now
restaurants working got the family let
me get into
politics so
let me throw that all away right well
you know being in the restaurant i mean
a lot of people come in there
complaining about the issues of the day
um i think you and i um could probably
relate with
being involved in republican uh politics
because we're both kind of new to that
i voted republican but i i wasn't paying
attention to who i was voting for why i
was voting for them
and what happened in between those
elections and so i'm actually fairly new
to that process i just know as a
business owner
they were affecting my business they
were affecting my family um they were
affecting the paychecks that we were
able to bring home i was electing
people who i thought had my same views
but then they would get to washington dc
or to the state capitol over regulate
over tax overspend and destroy
everything that we're trying to build at
home
and so we talk about that kind of stuff
in the restaurant and
i i really believe that um a lot of our
problems in america is because we had
an entire generation at least say you're
not allowed to talk about religion or
politics and now we have an entire
generation that is ignorant about the
things of god
and government and you're not allowed to
have that politics religion yes
basically yes exactly that that is their
god government is their god and that's
why they believe that government can
come in and rule you and you need to
submit and they can take rights away
from you because they are the grantor of
those rights speaking my language yes
yes and so um in my restaurant you're
free to talk about those things even if
you disagree with me
freedom of speech is so under attack
right now and if we lose that we lose
everything
hate speech is free speech
speech that you disagree with is free
speech and this is something that we
have to protect so this isn't just a
second amendment issue or a 10th
amendment issue
this is everything our our livelihoods
and everything moving forward we know
what big tech is doing to censor um
freedom of speech and really i it's the
first time in history that
big tech somewhat an entity this big
is more of a threat than big government
because this is someone playing the role
of government in your life and taking
things from you it's it's bizarre um
but
i didn't want to just sit and complain
about what was going on i wanted to be a
part of the solution
and i didn't know what that meant um but
suddenly uh there was this um
suave pretty boy from texas um who got
up on a presidential debate stage
and he slipped up um beta o'rourke told
the whole world what democrats plan to
do with your second amendment he said
hell yes we're going to take your ar-15s
and your ak-47s
so i got pretty upset and i drove to his
presidential rally my husband said what
are you doing well you that's three
hours away like we don't have the fuel
the the extra gas money to do that and i
said no i'm going to talk to this guy he
said you just think they're going to let
you talk to him it's like i don't know
i'm but i'm going very spontaneous so i
drove three hours to his presidential
rally
with my glock on my hip and uh i looked
him in the eye and told him hell no
you're not and i i
you know i was just so frustrated and
millions of americans were just as
frustrated as me and they were reaching
out to me saying thank you this is
exactly what we felt and i said who is
speaking up for them
and if if me just a mom of four boys
from rifle colorado a restaurant owner
can say something so impactful that the
nation listens
what else could i do to help bring
awareness to what's happening and hold
these people accountable and try to
try to make us a bad situation right
so a couple of months later i decided to
run for this
position
took on a five-term incumbent
and
everyone told me you can't do this you
will lose
and we were out spent ten to one i won
by ten points and it's because i had
the people's support i have a very large
district in colorado nearly half the
state and i have driven every bit of it
and connected with thousands and
thousands of people and i love them
i i love seeing them over and over and
over again and connecting with them and
hearing from them and it's just such an
honor to be their voice so you're kind
of appreciative of beto i assume if it
wasn't for him i mean everyone remembers
that moment like if it wasn't for him
saying something so profoundly
ridiculous right
it would have never opened the door for
this exactly
i wouldn't had anyone to yell at
so okay so you get to the capitol
and you know you're part of this new
crop of people and there's all these
young progressives and they're on the
cover of every magazine and everyone's
telling them you know they're all so
wonderful they're so perfect and
everything but they don't include you in
that they don't include dan crenshaw and
that somehow you guys actually are
basically framed as the bad guys right
can you talk a little bit about just how
the media
reacts to you guys more than anything
else yes well i i was a little prepared
for it coming into congress because
during the general election the media
spent over five million dollars trying
to make me look like a monster an
absolute criminal i have a mug shot
because i i didn't pay a hundred dollar
traffic ticket it's paid now but uh you
know you you go in you get your pretty
little picture taken and you know you
pay 100 bucks and you leave yeah
billboards everywhere plastered with my
with my mug shot and this lawbreaker
wants to be your lawmaker you know all
of this
yes
pretty pretty clever i would take
selfies with the billboards when i see
them you know like hey it's better than
my driver's license picture but uh but
then you get there get there and then
you see the reaction that they're
getting everyone because basically the
the leadership of the democrats seemed
like they handed them the keys to the
castle and the inmates are running the
asylum but you guys
nobody's really talking about you guys
right no um they they want us to be
quiet they want to demonize us and make
us look to be the enemy nancy pelosi has
called me the enemy within um we have
metal detectors outside of the house
chambers because of me
and uh
so so it seems so that was because you
said you were going to carry there and
she basically was like no you're not so
you're gonna yeah yeah and then whatever
happened because of that so that you
have to walk through
right the metal detectors or you're fine
ten thousand dollars
ten thousand dollars if you refuse to go
through the metal detector personal
money and uh
so i i have my firearm everywhere in the
capitol in the office except for the
house chambers
it's permitted for me to be everywhere
but there and so she put up the metal
detectors right outside the house
chambers i can go in the senate chambers
now
it's a little more free over there oh
that's free oh okay well she's not in
charge of that right exactly exactly and
so if you've ever been in the rotunda
you'll see um the statue of reagan and
if you look closely there's pieces of
the berlin wall
in that statue it's embedded in that
statue and i think somewhere right there
in the middle of the rotunda in the
capital is some sort of magic wall maybe
it's like the berlin wall because on one
side it's pure
authoritarian tyranny and then the other
side it's kind of free
sort of uh a metaphor for america i
suppose yes the states kind of go there
different ways so the media doesn't
treat you guys that great but what about
you know i've been talking a lot about
on the show lately about motives and
it's like do these people really know
the damage they are doing and i think a
lot of people think that their their
constituents don't their constituents
kind of think oh no they're trying to do
good
i'm kind of past the point where i think
that their motives are good because
they're doing so much damage have you
had sit downs
aoc on the rest of them have you had sit
downs with nancy like what do you think
is really
going on there um so i've not had sit
downs with them because they keep us so
divided and so separate and
previous
members of congress who have been there
previously they'll tell you it's never
been this way um there was always
communication between republicans and
democrats and now it is so divided and
that's by design
um she wants to keep us separate she
wants the house chambers empty
you're talking about it you're talking
about nancy nancy pelosi yes yes and and
she truly believes this is pelosi's
house not the people's house and so even
in the house chambers she wants us
masked up
it's a 2500 fine if we're not wearing
our mask but that's only where the
c-span cameras are rolling right it's
political theater and so you know for a
fact this is not you're not making
they're not wearing their masks in their
offices yeah with their staff i see them
right i see them walking in the halls as
soon as they leave the chambers they're
taking off their masks i've seen aoc
start to film a a selfie video which i
later saw on instagram and i knew
exactly where she was and where she was
doing it and she put on her mask and
then pretended to take it off for the
video i mean it's it's political theater
we've all seen her on on the capitol
steps oh we're going to take a picture
put on your mask i mean it's it's nuts
and so we have um we have a complete
invasion at our southern border and
americans are being punished with these
coveted policies
this fouchy funded chinese virus that is
absolutely affecting every part of our
lives our children i just pulled my kids
out of public school because they
brought back mass mandates and they're
not letting up on it and i said okay
well we're doing something else because
i'm not subjecting my children to this
again and uh and so we're pulling them
out and doing something on our own but
are you homeschooling now it'll be a
hybrid version of homeschooling yes and
and i need help for that you know i mean
i
i believe in this country and i believe
that we have an opportunity to get
things back on path
and if i didn't believe that i wouldn't
leave my four boys every single day to
do what i'm doing but i want them to
have a good future i have been here from
the beginning to make sure my boys never
have to live in a socialist nation
their freedom is my motivator and that's
why i'm stepping up to do what i can to
serve our country and uh so there
there's so much that's happening
i was at a columbus day event
and we found an immigrant that democrats
hate and it's christopher columbus
yes and you know it's interesting
because there was a couple of dozen
protesting my speech and and christopher
columbus but he said if you want to
protest immigration go to the southern
border this is an invasion that's taking
place you're calling christopher
columbus a rapist i've seen the rape
trees at the southern border i've been
there three times women's undergarments
hung from them as trophies i've seen the
young unaccompanied minors the young
teenage girls that have empty plan b
packaging
in their backpacks because their mothers
sent them on that journey with the plan
b pill expecting them to be sexually
assaulted
this is a crisis and unfortunately this
regime won't do anything about it i i
think they're sitting back and saying
mission accomplished that's what so do
you think it's that bad that you know i
think 10 years ago there were a lot of
republicans or conservatives that were
like you know the socialists are kind of
coming here that's really what we're
fighting and i think most people are
like oh you guys are kind of nuts you're
all on republic you know conservative
talk radio or something and now it seems
kind of obvious that that's what i mean
about the motives like i sort of don't
blame the the 18 year old kid who's
confused
uh but i do blame
now i would say the squad and pelosi and
and biden not that i think he's really
in charge you're welcome to comment on
that too um but like
are they just accomplishing what they
want to accomplish like we shouldn't be
we shouldn't be saying oh no no they're
trying to do good um i i do believe that
they're accomplishing exactly what they
want to accomplish
i was talking with lee zeldin
congressman from new york running for
governor and um i think he explained it
perfectly he said you know if you were
able to actually look into
some of these squad members hearts
if you were to look into rasheeda talib
ilhan omar is probably going to be
pretty black and evil and they are
accomplishing everything that they want
but if you were able to take a peek into
aoc's heart you're probably going to
find rainbows and unicorns
and she really just wants everything to
be cheerful and you know if if we just
pay for everything and provide
everything to everyone the world will be
wonderful and that's not the way it it
works um so i do believe that there are
different motives but unfortunately
they're all going the same direction and
it's a direction that we are trying to
stop we just want people to be free it
is not the proper role of government to
keep people healthy
to keep them safe in every aspect of
their life if so we wouldn't let people
drive cars
you know we would have somebody assigned
to them to make sure they're crossing
the street correctly and i mean there's
so many things that we would do to to um
to make sure that everyone is safe all
the time people drink soda soda i mean
as simple as that yes exactly and uh
and so with with all of this
um
we want people to be free that is the
proper role of government our our
founding fathers they had such an
amazing
spirit of faith they declared the end
from the beginning
they wanted to be independent they
wanted to be freed from an oppressive
tyrannical king and they declared that
independence before they had it they
celebrated that freedom before they were
free and then they went and fought that
battle for 11 more years until they
obtained it and and then they they
crafted the constitution
the most amazing document to ensure that
we keep these freedoms
that government is instituted to
to secure the rights of the people that
we the govern give consent to be
governed and there's a lot that we're
not consenting to anymore so is any of
it working right now i mean you know i
agree with everything you just said
obviously but like is any of it at any
level working right now when biden comes
out every day and we're not going to
respect states rights and and saki says
it's unquestionable that the federal
government has more power the power to
override the states and everything i was
like what
like what part of this thing is working
right now this is a question that i ask
every day um
because no it's not because they're
completely ignoring it um they they are
going against the constitution breaking
their oaths to defend and secure the
constitution on on a daily basis and
overriding the rights of the people
through executive orders uh you know
when i sit on a on an airline and i hear
that there is a federal law that says
that you have to wear a mask and say
well gosh i'm a federal lawmaker and i
don't remember making that law
i don't remember voting on that law
but you know this is the overreach of
the democrat party and i think a lot of
people are waking up to that um
certainly um i don't think that this is
a president that uh obtained 81 million
votes you know i think he would have a
little bit of confidence in his in his
base to at least answer questions um if
if this was such a popular president um
but i mean that that's neither neither
here nor there but i
i objected to the electoral college
results because the constitution was
violated and that's our biggest threat
right now is the complete disregard of
the constitution of the united states
you know you could go and try to find
votes in arizona votes in georgia
whatever hundreds of thousands of votes
ballots were mailed out right in our
faces against state constitutions
and the federal constitution
meaning because we change procedures
because of covid basically right exactly
because the state legislature has the
right to
change election laws and in six states
in particular it was not the state
legislatures that did that um no no
legislator uh
passed a law like that we had rogue
judges attorneys generals um secretaries
of state and unelected bureaucrats
changing election laws and so i mean
that's
that's the big
that that's what everyone's missing
right there that is why me and 146 other
republicans objected
in january and and then this has just
been spun out of control and we gotta
find ten thousand ballots so we gotta
find twenty thousand ballots no hundreds
of thousands were mailed out illegally
right in front of your faces what
percentage of your constituents do you
think care about this because i can tell
you after this california recall that
obviously didn't go the way that i
wanted to before and after almost
everybody that i spoke to and i
campaigned with larry elder almost
everyone that i spoke to
might literally be everyone i spoke to
during the campaign said dave do you
trust what's going to happen with the
results which they're already that's
their way of saying i don't trust what's
going to happen with the results so now
we've got like this
this
almost parasite in the system now of
belief or lack of yes
and
that is very concerning because it i
would say high 90s a high 90 percent
of the folks that follow me and are are
voting don't have trust in our election
um in our elections and i think there's
been a distrust for a long time
but this is the most blatant in your
face
form of distrust and
this this is something that we have to
keep communicating to people to show up
and vote i don't think that it helps any
of us to say oh well stay home
that doesn't help our country but we
have to have states securing their
election laws and making it easy to vote
and hard to cheat
we have to keep that pressure on these
states to do that i can't guarantee that
colorado will be changing their election
laws anytime soon with our democrat
super majority but in these other states
where they have the opportunity to do
something like georgia do it
strengthen that and and and give
confidence back to your voters how do
you guys fight the messaging though
because i covered all the election laws
the georgia stuff the texas stuff there
was nothing racist in it there was
nothing
against causing anyone to vote these
were things to make elections safer an
id you have to show an id when you rent
a golf club mini golf like basic things
but the messaging all is that you guys
are racist and you don't want people to
vote and you're stealing elections like
how do you beat that thing
um if there's anything that's racist
it's vaccine passports um because
there's actually uh you have to show an
idea right
exactly yes yes you have to show an id
to to get a vaccine and then even in
places like new york it's it's
more difficult to sit down in a
restaurant and eat than it is to cross
our southern border illegally right um
you know so i mean this is absurd so if
they want to talk about identification
being racist well let's flip it right
back on them and talk about these
vaccine mandates that are coming from
the white house
this is something that is affecting
people's livelihoods i'm so proud of
the nurses that have taken a stand the
southwest pilots that have taken a stand
i know um united had a victory um with a
judge that that put a pause on this are
you telling me that it wasn't just
weather that delayed those southwest i
heard joe biden he said it was just
weather yeah it wasn't just weather
maybe it was hurricane brandon i don't
know it was hurricane brandon it was
definitely that brandon guy yeah but but
but even that the way they blatantly lie
we all see what's happening you can look
at the weather radar yeah
could the weather only affect one
airline is that possible just one yes um
other airlines um had two percent of
their flights that were canceled
it's absolutely absurd but what do you
do with that i mean i keep driving it
home to this point but like that seems
to me the bigger issue than just that
they can lie get away with lies and call
you the liar and me the liar and all of
our audience the liar when they're
always lying but it seems to be working
yes we have to have conversations like
this joe rogan just confronted cnn about
about taking uh so-called horse medicine
horse through warmer he's like no you
said this
your
your uh company who you work for said
this cnn said it and you didn't stop
them you know oh yeah maybe that was bad
no no no but you didn't stop it and
that's what we have to do we have to
continue to call them out on what
they're doing look they have lied about
me from the beginning they said that i
led a reconnaissance tour january 5th
okay i don't even think i was in the
capital january 5th and
january 2nd i brought my family into the
capitol as a member elect with a capitol
hill police officer i had my four boys
my son my mom
and my husband and my mom so i'm sorry
sometimes he's like my son
and you know and we're we're looking
at this capital that i i'm about to be
sworn in as a member of congress and
um steve cohen chairman of the bad hair
caucus from tennessee
you know he
he sees us in the hall waves at us and
then goes on cnn and says i was leading
a reconnaissance to her like and they
and they are able to lie and get away
with this and this is something my
family has been attacked for received
death threats over my mom has received
um
death threats and even filed a lawsuit
um against a very notable um
influencer
he said that she was the bullhorn lady
on january 6th and the bullhorn lady
there's this woman with a pink hat and
she's got a bullhorn she's yelling and
she's like giving directions for people
we can't even find the bathrooms in the
capitol like we can lead a
reconnaissance tour give give people
directions and so you're right they're
able to lie all the time and they
absolutely get away with it uh and we
have to be there to expose the truth i i
think everyone we're created to
recognize truth and so if we keep
putting that out there more people will
gravitate to that truth i you did
i did yeah no i mean yes believe me
it's the only way i could do what i do
for a living if you didn't believe that
the truth matters then i don't know how
you could wake up and fight in congress
or talk about politics for a living
you'd basically go crazy but then the
other piece of that which you sort of
referenced already is the big tech piece
obviously which is now it's not only
that they can lie but their lies get
injected with steroids and our truth
gets actually cut off at the knees
because they won't let certain things
get out now it's even worse yeah can we
do about that miss congressman oh man um
well i i need a majority to do something
um because
republicans aren't going to be able to
fix this in the minority um there's no
democrat that's going to say yeah
republicans need a platform
they they they need to have this
censorship removed so they can have more
likes on on twitter and you know uh it's
so funny we we try to get something
trending we have the followers but they
don't see it and then you know just
after seven minutes lauren bobert is so
double trend number one all day long
because it's allowed to yeah because
they let it um
and uh so it's it's okay i have fun with
that stuff too you know i'm not i'm not
dumb enough to think that seven trillion
dollars equals zero so try again um wait
a minute so you're saying if you spend
3.5 trillion dollars that doesn't equal
zero yeah it doesn't equal zero it
doesn't equal true
gosh
yes but but that's another one
yes there are anti-trust laws for this
reason so these big companies these big
bullies can't suppress the little guys
like they did with with parlor you know
that was getting too big for them and
we we have to be in the majority to be
able to do something i know jim jordan
is working on legislation and i think
that's where it's going to take place um
i i think judiciary is going to get to
the bottom of this and we're going to
have some effective legislation um to to
make sure
section 230 is gone or
or at least
these companies are broke up whatever
that means i keep hearing they're gonna
break them up i don't know exactly what
that looks like um but
to break them up remove the the
liability protection and make them
accountable either they're a publisher
or their platform you have to choose one
yeah are you worried about obviously
we've talked about this a lot but are
you worried that if you remove 230 that
in essence they lose the protections and
then they're just going to crack down on
speech more because they're going to be
live
and then they're going to be like all
right we got to get rid of everything
that that is absolutely um a worry and
that's why you haven't seen just a
blanket removal of of section 230. um i
think that's why you didn't see
president trump um do away with section
230 because
there are details like this that we need
to look into but i'm really grateful um
that we have the jim jordans of the
world that are looking into this um
judiciary that that entire committee
there are brilliant minds serving there
and they just need the numbers to be
able to get their agenda passed they
need to be able to get that out there
because right now everything is party
lines um i mean even something as simple
as is removing a 200 million dollar
earmark for the presidio in nancy
pelosi's district you know that's
straight down party lines democrat says
no no she's the speaker she deserves a
little extra and she should get a little
extra ice cream in her right yeah
fridge and all that stuff um
do you ever think when you're at some of
these hearings like at this point when i
watch especially the big tech hearings i
watch him and jim jordan does do a great
job and i've talked to him about it but
when i watch these hearings it sort of
feels like we're just watching a movie
that we've all seen before yes
zuckerberg will say some nice things and
some things we disagree with the
whistleblower
this whistleblower who really is a lefty
activist will sort of say some nice
things but then also became like a
policy advocate for government
intervention but it's just like there's
a lot of talk it's a lot of talk it's
sort of interesting at some level and
then it's kind of like ah nothing ever
really matters
the next day he starts and there we go
right because the democrats won't allow
any progress to be made and they are in
the majority we congress is a majority
um rule body we are a self-governing
majority rule body so congress makes its
own rules for what happens in in those
chambers in those committee hearings and
the majority has the final say uh you
know you have you have leader mccarthy
who has offered a privilege
uh resolutions to remove someone who
can't get a civilian security clearance
um from the intel committee uh eric
swalwell and and but he's allowed to
have
this security clearance in congress on
the intel committee and they won't even
hear it they table the motion they say
no no we're not even discussing this so
i had mccarthy in here telling me just
that i mean in essence swallow was
sleeping with a spy like that's pretty
much what happened and everyone knows it
and nancy basically said to him i don't
care yes and that's what but he can get
away with it because he's a democrat
that's right that's right as long as you
have that d next to your name then yes
it's amazing what you could get away
with um but that's why we do hear a lot
of talk because
in the minority
that's what we have right now we we have
our talk
our job is to get in the democrats way
and then come home and tell our
constituents how we're getting in their
way we're exposing what they're doing
so that when we have that
majority we are able to hold them
accountable we are able to do something
and you know everybody likes to go back
to 2017 2018 when republicans had it all
and did nothing but forget that that's
why people like me are here that's why
cat cammack from florida is here and
mary miller from illinois and madison
cawthorne from north carolina beth van
dyne from texas ronnie jackson from
texas we have such an incredible
freshman class and we are here because
we looked at that majority and were
frustrated so what are you guys doing so
we need that back so we can actually
accomplish something we were we were all
pretty confident we were going to take
the house back and we would be able to
bring home victories to our districts
but we don't have those numbers we're
five short right now um so we need
people to show up in the next election
and make sure we are in a position to
actually put action behind our words to
do something about what we're saying how
worried are you though that this movie
has been played before and you're the
young crop now and you come in and
you're like we're gonna change the whole
damn thing and we're gonna do all the
stuff that nobody else did but then you
know five years go by you get reelected
once twice now you're in it for a while
and then it's like the swamp seems to
just envelope everybody right and i have
seen that
but i have a secret weapon so i am a
proud member of the freedom caucus and
there's about 40 of us right now and
it's it's incredible these are the
members of congress who are there for
the right reasons these are
your mark meadows uh your jim jordans
your andy biggs and and they are the
movers and shakers and the ones who who
aren't going to bow down just because
leadership says this is what we're doing
um these are the folks that will vote
against leadership because it's
unconstitutional because it goes against
their principles and the promises that
they made to their people so if we have
a 40 to 50 person voting block
in the majority
we have an ability
to have a voice in what's happening in
the republican party and um and that
voting block is very very important
i i do believe um leadership gets it
more than they have in the past and i i
hope that they stay in that direction um
but
we can't do things the way we always
have um so being a member of the freedom
caucus is so valuable to me because we
actually
debate the constitutionality
of anything that we're going to take a
position on we we debate the
constitutionality of procedures that
take place we are the ones that are but
is that the problem at some level i'm
with you why it's right and good and all
of those things of course but they're
not doing that right pelosi or or aoc
you mentioned before she's got rainbows
and unicorns in your head she's not
walking into any of those things and
talking to ilham be like we got to
figure out the the constitutionality of
this there well let's do it right yeah
is that is that a asymmetrical war that
is almost unwinnable so well you look at
the squad and they're kind of
the opposite of the freedom caucus but i
mean they are like the progressive
caucus right um they're in the democrat
party and they have a check on nancy
pelosi
she can't pass the infrastructure bill
without them
so instead she's looking to moderate
republicans saying
help us pass this infrastructure bill
right i take it no one's jumping over
right
yes
yes no one's jumping over no there are
republicans jumping over
and your viewers need to know it and
they need to be calling all of these
moderate republicans the ones who voted
for impeachment the ones who voted to
remove a voted with democrats to remove
a republican from her committee
assignments they need to be calling
these people and saying
do not pass the infrastructure bill the
1.5 trillion infrastructure bill because
that is the catalyst for the 5.5
trillion dollar budget reconciliation
it's not 3.5 it's not 4.3 it's 5.5 but
it's all zero also i'll zero that out
just to be clear so as of us taping this
at this moment i don't think there's
anyone publicly that is doing it but
you're saying that there are talks
behind the scenes and that some
republicans likely will break what do
they see as the win for that it's just
it's just that people they like being
pet republicans like they like being pet
on msnbc they're they're in really
they're in really tough districts so
they have to bring home the bacon for
their districts
and that means voting with democrats but
we can put forward a really good
alternative in fact i have i'm all for
infrastructure we all are president
trump i think he had a five trillion
dollar infrastructure plan you know i
mean even that was like pretty extreme
but he wanted to work with democrats on
infrastructure
i have an infrastructure bill the
american uh infrastructure modernization
act the aim act
650 billion dollars which is more that
that's uh currently allocated for
infrastructure in their bill
and because everything's infrastructure
right everything yes your mind it's the
most important infrastructure they're
focused on human infrastructure and uh
so 650 billion dollars no new money
spent
no tax increases because you're using
the unspent coveted funds that's already
approved by congress and it's paid for
there's more than a trillion dollars
unspent sitting there approved let's use
that for infrastructure it's done
i i introduced this piece of legislation
the moment they started talking about
infrastructure i said there is a way to
do this without spending new money and
without raising taxes on the american
people and it's it's there i'm not just
rubber stamping a no saying you don't
get your bridges and your ports i have a
good alternative solution um but no
there's there's probably um
i i would say a good 10 republicans if
if we don't get enough pressure out
there that will help get this
infrastructure bill passed look i hope
i'm wrong
where does uh i hope you're wrong too
for the record um where does biden fit
into all this because i just simply
cannot believe that this man is in
charge and and if you agree with me who
who is running the show at this point he
he has he has his staff that's
absolutely running the show um it's
it's really sad uh i i was um just
talking the other day i was looking at
the white house schedule for
the president of the united states and
it says uh 8 30 a virtual briefing 10 45
of another briefing and then that was it
called it a lid um so where is biden i
don't know he's napping he's eating his
applesauce it's it's sad today i saw um
a
a press conference
and again no questions because only
scripted joe can talk unscripted joe is
cancelled
are any of the democrats that are
willing to talk to you on the dl are
they acknowledging this
i i mean maybe none of them are willing
maybe let them talk to you i don't know
right um you know i
i i really uh i really like henry
cuellar i haven't talked to him about
biden but we talk about the border often
he has a brother that's border patrol
and he serves a border district and i
mean he's just disgusted in what's
happening at the southern border and so
i would think that there is some
frustration in the democrat party but
then again i mean i was at the
congressional baseball game and i may or
may not have been starting some chat
chants when i saw
joe biden come out you know let's go
brandon um but uh i mean the democrats i
mean they're just so excited oh my gosh
he's here he's awake
and
so i i don't know it's really
frustrating even when he came to
congress to talk to the democrats
we all thought he was coming to whip the
vote
hey get it together we're passing this
infrastructure we're passing the uh
budget reconciliation but he actually
just came to say we don't have the votes
nancy couldn't tell her own conference
that she had to drag joe out of the
white house to tell the conference yeah
we don't have the votes why couldn't she
tell him because she's afraid of them
you mean i i think there was a big shame
uh factor in that and this is supposed
to be um
reflective of her entire career in
congress this is this is supposed to be
it this is and and she can't get it
what do you think republicans or
conservatives can do to take the people
say that were like me five years ago
that were democrats their whole life
progressives i was a bernie supporter in
2016. obviously not that way anymore
poor bernie uh poor poor bernie they
used him and now he's done he and he
just seems like a muppet on twitter he
seems like a parody of bernie sanders on
twitter but what do you think you guys
can do messaging-wise to make all of the
disaffected liberals like the not crazy
progressives the anti-identity politics
liberals the bill maher types that get
it about free speech that you know that
are maybe more libertarian in certain
ways
to say hey
we're not as scary as they think because
that's still what i see is the big thing
i meet so many people that are like dave
you know i'm with you on a lot of this
but now it seems like you're a
conservative or something i don't nobody
likes that this it's the c word it's the
other c word basically crazy
it's almost worse it's worse yes
yes
we have to have these open conversations
with people because i think we've always
been the pop the party of tolerance and
acceptance uh we're the party of freedom
and if if that doesn't scream from the
rooftops that we want you in in our
party then i don't know what does um you
have people mocking freedom i had
someone respond to my twitter
saying that
freedom isn't free i'll take higher gas
prices over authoritarianism
any day like what do you think this is
they they're
spending 80 million dollars on uh
on the irs um and doubling their agents
and they want to sift through your bank
accounts to make sure that there isn't
any crime going on uh that's what
they're about 600
anything over 600 that's what they want
to double the irs workforce yeah these
these bureaucrat bullies to come in and
and we've already seen what happens when
you weaponize the irs they come after
conservatives after the c word and and
it's like with lois lerner we've seen it
already we saw even just this year the
irs releasing private information about
people who donated to republicans and
and so what what about that
doesn't scream authoritarianism uh and
and of course the vaccine mandates you
know i heard i heard biden say that we
have to get 44 million more americans
vaccinated because we have to bring
unity well what about
get this or you're fired
says unity
it's incredible i've said from the very
beginning this is a personal decision
between you and your doctor talk to your
doctor my doctor has never mandated
anything but he's always given me his
best advice and and made suggestions
made sure that i had all the information
that i needed and now we have
bureaucrats and politicians making
health mandates right and also the fact
that basically everyone's screaming that
their four mandates right now would be
against it if orange man was president
they said it when he was in the white
house
as soon as he mentioned vaccine they all
were up in arms uh if this was donald
trump's vaccine i ain't doing it kamala
literally said that joey reid who would
trust the cdc now right exactly and and
so it's it's all about their narrative
their players and and elevating them and
and where they want to go uh you know
what do you think they're really trying
to accomplish with this vaccine mandate
like or do you think this do you think
they're really trying to keep us safe is
that what this really is they're trying
to keep us safe a year and a half later
from kovid i think uh the words of
president reagan um still ring true the
most dangerous nine words in the
american language is i'm here from the
federal government and i'm here to help
yeah i'm from the federal government i'm
here to help i mean that is that is so
dangerous and there is nothing more
permanent than a temporary government
program i mean look at uh
look at the tsa
you know we we weren't always supposed
to uh stick with three ounce bottles you
know that was supposed to be temporary
here we are 20 years later i know
there's a lot of nice tsa people but
maybe they're not all as on the ball as
they should be but then what do you
think really is is the goal this chinese
social credit system i mean i had rand
paul on two weeks ago he believes that's
where this is headed that was conspiracy
alex jones stuff five years ago and now
it seems like it's here
yes um i see democrats who are envious
of the chinese communist party every day
they want to outsource our energy
to china i serve on the natural resource
committee and i i'm so happy to serve
there because i told everyone i would be
their voice i would fight for them i
would secure their rights but i promise
to work for them and being on the
natural resource committee gives me a
seat at that table and i have these
conversations on a regular basis about
american energy independence pursuing
energy dominance right here in america
and they want everything outsourced and
it's just it only empowers china and
weakens us everything about their
policies makes us weaker um there was
there was a man who came into the
committee room and he
wasn't very happy with the industry
and he said you know i started working
at this oil and gas company and we were
drilling for natural gas in north dakota
and it was it was really hard work you
know one week in seven days i worked a
record 95 hours i was in there 95 hours
what like that's nothing so i got on
there talked to him and said sir
i too remember my first part-time job
but i'm not in this committee room
bragging about it but he he went on to
say that he has seen artificial
hyperinflation
take place when these companies come
into communities i live in a community
where we had a boom and that boom didn't
have to go away i've seen the schools
built the roads the
the fire departments the hospitals the
colleges and the the small businesses
that opened my small business that
opened and we were able to flourish and
having mud on our floor meant that
things were really going good and people
were coming in and patronizing your
business i saw moms
not have to work because dad had a good
paying job they could raise their babies
i was that mom for a while and
i've also seen
politicians step in
and regulate our communities into
poverty
that is artificial
nothing about the success was artificial
but that regulation is it didn't have to
happen and they want to outsource all of
this
to china and africa in africa we have 40
000 children
mining with their bare hands for cobalt
in the congo
selling it to china and we are buying
solar panels from them these not in my
backyard extremists don't understand
what's happening with these policies and
and what condition they're creating for
people in other countries and they think
that they're doing something great but
they're not right or they really
literally mean it as long as it's not in
my backyard i don't care yes at some
level right that's the intentions part
yes no you're exactly right i actually
met um a very very wealthy woman in uh
new york and there was
a um she
she wasn't my biggest fan but there was
a
there was a wind farm that was going to
be put literally in her backyard right
across the road
furious
move it down the road why don't you put
it down here there's nothing over there
why don't you put it in this
neighborhood not in mine he's well ma'am
you voted for this this is what you
wanted but you don't want it in your
backyard it's for other people
um all right i think i only got one more
for you which is so with all of this in
mind i think a lot of people are
suddenly talking about this idea that
the future of america is just going to
be the states kind of going their
separate way that just if you live in
florida or texas it's going to be very
different than if you live in california
new york maybe that's already the way it
is
you in colorado are you know somewhere
kind of in between on that but do you
see that sort of as just an
inevitability and maybe that's okay
maybe that's sort of how the federalist
system was supposed to work in the first
place
i i do think that it's okay um i don't
want this authoritarian federal
government i want to shrink the federal
government as much as possible i don't
think that there should be a federal
department of education
i want the federal government out of our
lives and and we do need to get back to
states
having ultimate rule
unfortunately you do get people in these
positions where
they seem to have unchecked powers they
have emergency orders and they're able
to shut down small businesses they're
able to stifle innovation and and tax um
their
their citizens um
to a point of poverty and so you've seen
it in california we're starting to see
it in colorado and so i mean that's
obviously the the negative aspect of um
of having states have their own rights
is because it can be a really bad place
if you have bad people making these
decisions but then you do have the right
to move to somewhere that is more free
like i don't want to have to move to
south dakota but i will move to america
if i have to and so i can read the
subtext here you're looking at me like
yeah the weather's nice and cali today
but what are you doing here
but you see that not necessarily as a
totally negative thing though because
then it does give the opportunity for
the other states absolutely i mean there
there definitely needs to be competition
between these states let let states
compete for
for their citizens to have the best
people move to their state um there's a
lot of bright minds moving to texas into
florida right now
companies moving to these to these
states and and they're going to make
these states better places
you know we have magpul they they used
to solely be in colorado and they moved
to wyoming because their gun laws are
better
and they are the number two employer in
wyoming they want to come back to
colorado he said we can't your gun laws
are outrageous it's it's
near impossible to have a business there
you know the way the way we're starting
to be taxed and regulated so we're in
wyoming and when things change let us
know we'll come back
tesla just left cali to go to texas yes
so there might be a theme here
exactly and so i would love for colorado
to be an example one day of how free we
can be um bringing energy
development back and um and and doing it
cleanly um you know we we have that
ability there nobody produces energy
better than we do and and to have um
to have everything that our founders
envisioned for our country right there
in one state i would love to see that
for colorado and many more states all
throughout our nation
congresswoman your work is cut out for
you but i wish you the best of luck and
i'm glad we finally did this we were
good we met once in 2019 at a turning
point thing for a second yeah and we
agreed to do a show and then we
basically waited two years because we
wanted to do it in person right thank
you for coming in thank you so much dave
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell